[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> Thank you.
I'm Jim Breyer.
I'm a venture capitalist with Accel Partners
in Palo Alto.
And I've been on the board of Facebook and
an investor in Facebook for
about five years.
>> What's your next investment?
>> Well, we have -- we have about a dozen
investments in social media
companies around the world.
And Julia, and for any other panelist that
might be interested, what
can we as either business investors or part
of the business community
around social media do better for further
many of these causes that
we've talked about today?
JULIA LALLA-MAHARAJH: I'm going to talk to
you afterwards one-on-one
because I need your advice.
Absolutely, I was talking about someone just
the other day about how he
uses mobile phones to get medicines into villages.
And able to predict supply and demand in a
much, much clearer way.
And having been out in Africa, knowing the
growing use of that sort of
technology is absolutely crucial.
I mean, imagine if this network of -- as we
said before taking things
to scale, imagine if we can do that through
empowering community
leaders to -- you know, even if it's someone
saying that there's a
cutting ceremony that's due to take place
within two months.
And then being able to gear up around that.
I think there's so much that can be done and
the empowerment around
that is huge.
But also what I found through my experience
is how many people have
contacted me globally so this is not just
about what the West can do.
I had some much e-mails from people in Cameroon,
in Guinea, in all
sorts of places saying what can I do in my
own community?
And one thought is just about, you know, there's
not one database, for
example.
That's someone contacted me from Guinea-Bissau
to say can I download
from the web?
I'm about to teach this class.
What can I download from the web?
I couldn't find a single place where that
person could just go to be
able to say to their community these are the
issues that you could deal
with.
So we need to hit this straight on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]